[Music]
[Music] Let's
tell the monkey that we've set you free. As
time passes, he
'll forget all about you. Well, all you have to do is change his mind, even if it takes 100 years.
You're in my way first.
[Music]
Just do something and they'll cut you.
They're stupid, after all. There's
no other way to do things than to control them by their wings, even if they're just fairies.  If you
can't obey me, you can't become one. You
can subdue those fools without having to hold the wings. I have the
freedom of fairies. I
don't need a king. I'm looking for something else. But
before that,
our pride is in the hands of humans.  It will perish.
After all,
I am the only Fairy King, and I
will rule over you too.
[Music]